c'est le petit dernier de la collection
ce noir atlas arrivé il ya deux semaines
est un avion à double creux qui s'ouvre
à l'arrière pour pouvoir charger de la
marchandise ou sauter en parachute
son premier vol date de 1959 il ya eu de
carrière il a une carrière militaire où
ils transportaient donc ce que je vous
ai dit du matériel militaire et des
parachutistes ou des trous des troupes
et ensuite il a été vendu à une société
qui s'appelle transvaal rc leur atlas
numéro 180 et qui travaillait qui
voulaient travailler pour la sernam et
il ya eu des problèmes avec avec la
sernam et en fait cet avion n'a pas eu
le temps de travailler
pierre farman le président de
l'association est le petit-fils de dick
norman pionniers de l'aviation qui a
oeuvré à la naissance d'air france c'est
grâce à sa famille connue dans le monde
aéronautique que de nombreuses personnes
lui donne des pièces au lieu de les
jeter
cette parcelle à deux pas des pistes de
l'aérodrome devient une sorte de musée à
ciel ouvert qui a quand même une
particularité on n'aura pas jamais le
droit d'y rentrer c'est ce sont des
avions des montées donc contendant s'il
fallait sécuriser on aurait pu la place
de mettre autre chose donc on est
extrêmement près de la clôture et on
regarde à travers clôture et on peut
donc y voir deux avions le nord atlas et
un falcon 900 mais aussi un pas de
pièces détachées comme un morceau de
falcon 50 et une entrée d'air de boeing
il ya des volets des ailes de des
morceaux de turbines
de l'autre côté un train d'atterrissage
quoi il ya un petit peu de tout l'idée
est vraiment de faire sortir de son
contexte les les pièces d'avion pour
montrer comment commencer fabriquer la
prochaine acquisition de l'association
sera certainement un moteur de mirage et
d'autres pièces devraient arriver
également en novembre ainsi que des
panneaux d'affichage sur la clôture pour
donner des détails sur ces objets